alors eric naulleau c'est vous qui avez
obtenu cette interview exclusive de la
grand mère maternelle d'alexandre et
yann moix
comment ça s'est passé vous dire que moi
depuis le début je suis indigné qu'on
essaie de faire passer la victime qu'il
ya deux mois que pour le bourreau c'est
la version de la famille du frère et des
parents donc j'ai cherché un témoin qui
pourrait trancher entre les deux
versions j'ai entendu parler de la
grand-mère par un intermédiaire j'ai
demandé un rendez-vous
j'ai demandé s'il voulait accorder une
interview elle m'a répondu qu'elle
n'accorderait d'interviews cas moi je
peux demander pourquoi mais c'est comme
ça que ça s'est passé je suis donc allé
la voir chez elle je lui dis une
dernière fois vous n'êtes pas obligé de
donner cette interview parce qu'elles
hésitaient parce qu'elle savait que ça
allait mal se passer avec la famille ce
qui est le cas depuis que on a diffusé
des extraits hier elle est harcelée par
alexandre moix qui n'avait pas appelé sa
grand mère depuis dix ans et qui depuis
la harcèle au téléphone
elle s'est également fait incendier par
sa fille une fois que je lui ai rappelé
une dernière fois
elle a commencé à parler est ce qu'elle
raconte à mon avis est la vérité ultime
sur cette affaire et elle est agrémentée
si j'ose dire d'éléments qui sont
fracassants ce qu'elle raconte je ne me
suis même pas revenu mon ami alors elle
vous a livré donc sa vérité et pour vous
c'est la vérité elle se souvient
notamment d'un coup de téléphone de la
mer de yann moix dans lequel elle
explique vouloir démolir son fils des
propos qui l'ont profondément choqué
regardez c'est le premier extrait de
l'interview de la grand-mère de yann
moix et là moi je suis désolé pour yann
parce que c'est un gamin qui méritait il
s'est fait sa carrière tout seul il a
beaucoup dit il avait beau du mérite là
on est en train de détruire sa carrière
c'est déjà fait et puis un jour ma fille
qui m'a téléphoné à dix toute façon on
va le démolir j'ai trouvé ça de la part
des parents un faible hiziv quand même
même si on n'aime plus ou moins gtld
fallu préférence on a quand même pas
arrivé à ce point alors moi je trouve là
ça va trop loin
là non seulement est détruit sa carrière
mais c'est lui même qui sont en train de
détruire
il paraît qu'elle aurait demandé donc à
la maire de gan watts vous voulez sa
mort et sa fille donc la mère de yann
moix aurait répondu non voulu gâcher sa
vie il ya une volonté
libéré de nuire à yann moix à travers ce
qu'il a de plus précieux c'est à dire
son oeuvre de dire que ce qu'il a écrit
n'a aucune valeur parce que c'est un
mensonge de on peut pas faire plus cruel
envers un écrivain alors la grand-mère
derniers mois que je reviens bien sûr
sur la maltraitance dont son petit fils
a été victime vous allez nous dire après
ce que vous pensez de tout ça si vous
pensez que c'est la vérité ou pas dont
son petit fils a été victime elle parle
d'humiliation récurrentes donc elle
prend fait et cause pour yann moix et lx
et lui donc qu'ils étaient victimes de
maltraitance regarde lesquelles un
enfant de robes et affectueux tendre
comme tout mais non comme tout mais ses
parents de prendre le long jamais mais
jamais vu ian avec des coûts n'est rien
du tout par contre c'était plutôt
l'humiliation des choses une
maltraitance morale presque un python
physique physique aussi naturellement
mais il était toujours rabaissés humilié
et ce genre reproche toujours un peu a
fixé que l écouter trop ce qu'alexandra
comptait alors si yen qui prenait puis
alexandre rideau les endosser son père
quand il rentrait c'est pareil devant
dépôt ce qui s'était passé et toujours
yens tu feras un message au mal supporté
donc là elle dit clairement donc c'est
la version de yann moix qui est la bonne
version
jean michel maire on va avoir d'autres
extrême est là pour vous c'est enfin la
vérité vous qui redécouvrit comme nos
téléspectateurs on les soutient une gêne
c'est que monet matin à compter chaque
participant combien il a de soutien
conneries mais bon là là où elle paraît
très sincère c'est une grand mère en
général ne m'ont pas c'est vrai que la
parole où j'ai envie de dire passer
comme les enfants une grand mère je les
imagine difficilement mon tir j'ai
tendance à croire mais c'est vrai que
j'espère qu'on va pas entendre un autre
grand père de l'autre côté qui va dire
le rcl n'a pas lu le livre une part les
ans parce que yann moix contrairement à
son habitude n'a pas souhaité lui
envoyer parce qu'il ne voulait pas
l'exposer à ce qu il yad émotionnelle
dans ce livre ce que dit cette femme est
parfaitement raccord avec ce que dit
yann moix dans les ans donc on peut
imaginer tous les complots du monde je
trouve que c'est un élément troublant la
deuxième élément ce qu'elle dit et c'est
un des six rounds
retiens c'est que alexandre noir cessé
de vouloir nuire à son frère avec des
moyens d'enfants quand il était enfant
et de vouloir lui nuire avec des moyens
d'adultes quand il était adulte il n'y a
aucun doute
alexandre donc le frère de yann moix a
toujours été jaloux diane et cette
polémique sur une sorte de vengeance
regardez il ya le réussissez en crise
qu'il faisait c'était et c'est vrai que
déjà on réussit bien comme il faut il a
fait son chemin il a quand même fait
maxime affûté je pense que ça et
alexandre on a toujours été un petit peu
jaloux et aujourd'hui la façon qui le
décrit la cholière poster il attendait
que ça a fait comme un effort qui après
ça prologue
il raconte des histoires qui sut rien
qui nécessite un pas du tout ça j'en
suis certaine
alors la version donc de la grand-mère
voyez là elle l'a c'est clair un arriéré
beinheim non mais évidemment c'est
toujours très compliqué mais on est
toujours très gêné d'assister un
déballage dans une famille comme ça sur
des thèmes qui sont aussi douloureux est
aussi difficile sont bien obligés voilà
voilà
et on rappelle que évidemment les
enfants battus certains thèmes qui
effaçait tu veux quelque chose
d'extrêmement important et délicat il
faut pas jouer avec ça et donc remettre
en cause la parole de quelqu'un qui dit
qu'il a été battu cccd dicale à cette
grand mère semble prendre fait et cause
pour un de ses petits enfants
on nous on est pris à témoin donc que
faire d'autre que de dire ben voilà on
est un peu pris à témoin on ne sait pas
vraiment comment alors je vous le dis
donc c'est vrai quand une interview
exclusive qui a réussi à voir eric
naulleau à la grand mère maternelle de
yann moix donc vraiment c'est pour ça
qu'on pose la question enfin la vérité
elle fait aussi des révélations
surprenantes sur alexandre moix donc le
frère de yann moix ses parents auraient
eu des gros problèmes avec lui regarder
alors des problèmes à certains moments
parce que ses parents est obligé de le
mettre en location en hôpital
psychiatrique et arrêté plusieurs mois
et étaient pour bien du tout et puis bon
le fait de qui là les soi-disant sur ces
courts alors qu'il était avec des
copains entre un fichu le feu dans les
boîtes aux lettres un petit patelin
enfin il n'est que des trucs comme ça
mais
lui c'est ça passait il ya toujours été
sur loire faux jeton caché son jeu
il faisait celui qui était bien comme ça
pour se faire bien voir mais en fait non
c'était pas ça du tout ce qui apparaît
ce qui apparaît dans cet extrait dans
tout l'entretien c'est qu'il ya un cas
d'inversion quand alexandre moix dit mon
frère des problèmes psychologiques c'est
de lui qui parle c'est lui qui a fait
des séjours en asile psychiatrique
quand il dit mon frère était proche des
milieux d'extrême droite c'est lui
alexandre qui était proche des milieux
d'extrême droite une bonne maman du
groupe qui a fait 7 cet attentat contre
chirac aux champs elysées mais donc je
sicot logiquement il ya quelque chose de
très troublant c'est qu'il inverse
complètement il tout ce qu'il dit de lui
concerne yann moix et inversement
riaient de moi que ça à la riche
héritière paris m'était projets
extrêment c'est pas la même chose à lyon
d'être dans un groupe qui prépare un
attentat et je les regardais elle le
raconte ça elle dit voilà que alexandre
a nié avoir appartenu
si alexandre a nié avoir appartenu à des
groupes d'extrême droite donc le frère
de yann moix pour sa grand-mère la
réalité bien différente
regardez elle affirme qu'il a eu ses
fréquentations et fait qu'il faisait
partie d'un groupe d'extrême droite ça
j'en suis certaine parce qu'il ya un
monsieur qui fait partie des
renseignements généraux qui avait été au
courant qu'ils avaient vu que alexandre
était avec la non et au moment où il ya
eu d'attentât contre chirac qui s'est
renseigné parce qu'il ya eu vraiment eu
peur qu alexandre en fasse partie
ce jour-là il y était pas les tpo là
mais en fait c'est lui parce que moi je
n'avais jamais vu à le fourrer dans les
tons pareil donc c'est alexandre au
maximum mais il n'était pas mouillé dans
la tentative de berne à monter dans ma
faim
c'est quand même terrible qu'on m'entend
aussi c'est en visitant la grand mère
n'aime pas alexandre moi donc c'est
quand même violent ce qu'elle dit sur
lui les enfants sont partis
les deux enfants étaient des sans droits
télé 2 c'est pas la même chose aux
renseignements généraux pour appartenir
à une mouvance terroriste faut quand
même appeler les choses par leur nom
il n'était pas impliqué dans l'attentât
en fait il était il était dans secondes
et avoir des amitiés douteuses comme
yann moix que je ne soutiens pas sur ce
point là mais c'est pas la même chose
pardonnez moi benjamin castaldi
non moi je veux honnêtement depuis le
début j'ai pris fêter est ce que pour
vous la question est simple enfin la
vérité oui moi je pense que oui on a
évoqué avec eric eric sur ce plateau par
principe j'ai j'avais tendance à croire
ce que disait il ya un mois que sur son
passé d'enfant battu il ya eu un
déferlement contre lui on a évoqué ici
tout le passé du frère et tout ce qu'il
avait fait avant quand il ya deux mois
que je fais un a eu un livre sur les
sosies il a fait la même chose ça
s'appelait curriculum ensuite à faire un
bouquin que la wii bien sûr il a il a
passé son temps ce garçon alexandre à la
pompe et son frère a copié son frère
dans tout ce qu'il a pu faire et écrire
et après on a un garçon qui se transpose
dans une autre réalité c'est un cap
psychologique est intéressant mais pour
le coup extrêmement réaliste et quand on
s'intéresse un peu même si le logis ça
arrive souvent
je suis très content que ce soir la
grand mère qui est content que tu dis
juste des fonds son petit fils qui a été
traîné dans la boue à qui on a coupé la
route du goncourt à qui on a fait des
choses épouvantables
alors effectivement on peut on peut
disserter 107 ans en huit ans sur son
passé et serra alors parle pas de sang
parle de ce qui s'est passé là pour une
famille tu as un mec qui dit tout et
n'importe quoi sur son frère et moi je
suis content que la grand-mère et
défendu son petit fils alors à la
regarder les interview d'alexandre qu'il
a donnée à la télévision et a trouvé ses
propos très étrange regarder l'autre
jour quand je l'aï entendu à la télé moi
j'ai eu l'impression que ce qu'il a vécu
il le fichu rien et puis par contre ce
qu'il y en avait que c'est sur leurs pas
sur lui
j'ai l'impression que tout c'est bizarre
et puis ensuite je les ai vus les yeux
comme s'il était renvoyé personne qu'il
était dans son âge
qu'il a parlé de psychiatres de
d'extrême droite est en fait c'était son
histoire à lui qui racontait les trucs
d'extrême droite et tout ça il ya une
heure il ya un âge à 8 5 appareils
jamais donc en fait ce qu'elle est dans
un dire c'est que le frère de également
assuré alexander mc s'est substitué
voilà on ne peut pas le dire plus
clairement pas à ça et à revisiter toute
l'histoire vous allez voir que ce que
dit la grand mère correspond exactement
aux déclarations d'alexandre d'eau pour
vous un disque c'est la mémoire
pour autant que je puisse être
affirmatif que je suis sûr qu'elle dit
la vérité et n'a aucun intérêt a
sûrement mais non parce que voilà alors
alors non mais oui christophe carrière
elle ne dit pas la vérité elle dit sa
vérité comment tu peux préféré jeu mais
non c'est sa vérité contre celle
d'alexandre excuse moi
la visite est chez elle est ce que tu as
vu la pièce le musée qu'est dédié à yann
moix est là une vénération pour son
petit-fils ans neva retourne chez elle
et va voir la pièce il ya des photos de
partout où il ya tous les le livre j'ai
bien l'acheter orléans elle n'a pas
attendu le gall moi je lui envoie non
voilà il ya ça et moi y'a un truc qui
m'apparaît frêche le lycée de navarre tu
as dit que tu as lu l'interview par un
intermédiaire oui très curieux de savoir
par l'intermédiaire battu doigt c'est
une très jolie jeune femme tu gagnerais
à la connaît les noms mais parce que sa
vie n'a pas derrière son foods a on va
vers l'interview du père de yann moix à
ce moment là non mais hillary simplement
qu en 1h15 d'entretien elle a fait
justice de tous les mensonges qui ont
été déversées sur ian walsh et elle te
donne une la vérité d'un témoin
privilégié c'est pas machin qui a vu
c'est la grand-mère qui a passé
l'enfance avec ses petits fils durant
toute leur enfance qui les a gardés
pendant les vacances elle voyait quand
je la vérité alors qu'elle marque de
leur enfance oui justement elle dit qu
alexandre moix et alexandra yann moix
elle revient sur ce qu'il m'a dit un
pédiatre à l'époque tu as parlé de yann
moix
regardez
il était très bien lors du coup j'ai
pris rendez vous il m'a dit mais qu'est
ce qu'ils fassent vit pourtant j'en vois
les gamins j'ai jamais vu un gamin aussi
stressé aussi en pieux donc m étais ils
se plaignent et port et on savait qu'il
y avait quelque chose
par contre son père je sus que quand il
était gamin il a été maltraité
il est également dit vous savez il ya
des gens comme ça qui ont été maltraités
et qui se reportent ça sur leur ensemble
et je crois que c'est ça qui était
arrivé avec elle et orgue avec n
regarde moi je pense effectivement qu'on
assiste enfin à la vérité sur cette
affaire alors que je faisais partie de
ceux non pas qu'ils s'étaient mis à
douter ou a accusé yann moix de mentir
ou de fabuler mais c'est vrai que le
parti pris de son frère avait ainsi eu
un doute chez moi je savais plus très
bien comment de positionner sauf que il
faut toujours se poser la question de
quel quel est l'intérêt là dedans
l'intérêt des parents de yann moix de
réfuter son oeuvre et son témoignage est
évident ils veulent laver leur nom et
oppose une version totalement opposées
d'intérêt du frère être sur le devant de
la scène faire parler lui se faire
connaître et ses îles il est assez clair
également l'intérêt d'une grand-mère et
que tu l'as dit clairement qu'elle avait
hésité à livrer ce cette interview il
est il est nul il l a reçue elle a reçu
des menaces et aujourd'hui donc la
journée
ils ont appelé plus d'une dizaine de
fois la famille yann moix est long il
avait menacé
c'est ce que vous le savez mais pensait
pas que ça prendrait cette forme aussi
hystérique elle est harcelée au
téléphone par tout le reste du clan
c'est vraiment une interview excusé
c'est vraiment un document la suivre
tout le monde se soit pour rétablir ont
pas la vérité sur cette affaire en tout
cas dans la vérité d'un témoin quand
même sa grand mère c'est un témoin
important et pour l y avait des signes
comme cette fois où yann attentat a
tenté d'échapper au domicile familial en
se cachant dans le véhicule de ses
grands parents ont écouté cette anecdote
est apte il était petit oui et anxieux
il était une fois je n'ai eu là c'est
pareil je l'avais gardé un petit moment
pour l'hiver et puis au moment de partir
on cherchait gagnent partout pour les
dire au revoir
impossible de trouver on dans la voiture
y était cachée dans la boîte heures pour
vous d'y revenir
des trucs quelques à l'époque parce que
quand même quand on a des parents on est
contente toujours de retrouver ses
parents de rester et ses parents les
grands parents c'est que passager tu là
il voulait toujours revenir avec nous
donc c'est vrai que ce témoignage est il
est quand même assez poignant ça
commence à faire beaucoup et puis
surtout ce qui est extravagant c'est que
à quel point la parole d'un enfant battu
et est remis en cause ce qui n'arrive
presque jamais l'enfant est au contraire
sacralisé de nos jours bon il dit que ça
s'est passé on discute pas yann moix ça
leur tente et soupçonnable tout devient
sujet à caution je trouve ça quand même
très éprouvant soit bien connaître la
vérité ou pas pour wii enfin la vérité
mais cette vérité elle était dans le
livre il y avait beau marquer roman mais
orléans qui raconte tout ça oui mais le
livre a été remis en cause donc
forcément je saurai donc c'est pour ça
que ça en fait ça a été vraiment un
enfant battu il a été battu mais oui
mais oui mais ça a été remis en cause
c'est pour ça qu'on fait ce débat
aujourd'hui
mais comment un homme extrêmement
brillant comme yann moix pardon comment
un homme extrêmement brillant combien de
mox ai eu envie de remettre tout ça sur
le tapis avec ce roman justement ce
n'est pas la première fois que sa sortie
du coup dans toute son oeuvre il parle
de l'enfance battu dans toute son oeuvre
depuis le début le premier roman 85 mis
la pression que c'est pas nouveau
puisqu'il sait pas ne sait pas ne sais
pas non plus il a entamé une trilogie
autobiographique et ça colle en roulant
alors simplement dernière extraits que
vous voudrez vous montrer c'est que la
grand-mère de yann moix est également
revenu sur l'émission de laurent ruquier
on n'est pas couché où l'émission était
chroniqueur son petit fils elle fait des
révélations étonnantes là tu regardais
et je me rappelle quand il a commencé
qu'il a su qu'il allait chercher l'or à
la magie attendait tant que thouars puis
après il a vite compris que ça lui plaît
dit qu'à moitié parce qu'il pouvait pas
dire ce qu'ils voulaient et du canton et
ça je l'avais remarqué je dis ça va pas
durer longtemps
parce que il est en train de dire
quelque chose qui était très intéressant
mais il y avait un petit coup d'oeil un
petit interrupteur de dire ça m'a bien
comme ça ils pouvaient jamais aller
jusqu'au bout il peut passer au général
elle donne son avis ils ont quitté ce
qu'il m'a donné alternativement certes
très intéressant moi je considère plus
ça comme une pièce maîtresse sont un jeu
d'échecs à est avancé dans le camp de
gamme moix mais peut-être qui aura
d'autres pièces qui vont de leur côté
vous dire contrecarrer s'annonce en tout
cas c'est très intéressant et c'est
essentiel comme élément c'est une pièce
maîtresse ça c'est dur parce que cette
pièce définitive je pense qu'avec tout
ce que je chéris franchement je pense
que demain ou après demain tu vas avoir
droit un droit de réponse d'alexandre
mois et ses droits sam est d'assurer ce
sont trois je viens c'est dur la série
qui nous a des documents
ces documents de sa grand mère c'est un
document ces intimidations de réserves
importantes c'est un témoignage très
après l'important vraiment que tu en
penses tu bah moi je sais moi d'abord ça
me fait de la peine que cette vieille
dame elle soit ne soit menacée après
j'aurai vraiment du fond du fond du
coeur j'aurais voulu car je salue ton
travail mais j'aurais voulu que ce soit
quelqu'un d'autre qui fasse ça qu'ils
fassent cette interview parce que du
coup moi ça me met un peu je me dis
c'est un peu bizarre
et surtout ce que je me dis c est ce que
est ce qu'on n'est pas en train de
sauver le soldat yann moix parce qu'elle
est en train de parler au début de
l'interview de dire oui ils veulent
casser la carrière de mon fils mais de
mon petit fils c'est lui tout seul qui
s'est cassé la carrière avec ses dessins
pourquoi on parle comme ça autant dire
que max ait pas des dessins mais tout le
monde l'a dit c'est inadmissible oui on
parle on parle du livre moi et moi je me
dis que d'entendre parler la grand mère
elle est parti pris et moi je moi je dis
c'est sa vérité c'est pas la vérité sa
vérité c'est que ça sur moi j'aime bien
sûr que j'ai pas l'explication elle a
dit je ne veux parler vrai que nous la
can où l'on sait par contre en contact
ensuite un témoin de parti-pris écoute
excuse rare mais ça fait un mois qu'ils
subissent sans broncher il ya quelqu'un
qui te dit qui est bien placé quand même
pour détenir la vérité là communiqué et
toi ta réponse est lé parti pris a
besoin et oui moi j'ai pas entendu
quelqu'un sait ce que j'ai entendu
beaucoup de défis interventionnelle je
n'avais jamais entendu alors elle joue
un garde sait ce que c'est ce que
ressent raymond et ne sont pas on peut
ressentir lui voilà que c'est
la même fourni des éléments factuels
pourquoi il n'était jamais apparu dans
l'ue mais regarde à dix s'est caché dans
trois voitures aussi je me suis caché
dans le coffre de la voiture de ma
grand-mère et ils m'ont ramené c'est pas
plus face à l'austérité pour voler des
truffes se compose ses téléspectateurs
et alors enfin la vérité oui à 45 disons
non à 55 ans ont passé assez c'est assez
partagés j'ai fait ça